it was a long time coming but
microsoft's console has finally taken
the coveted number one spot off sony's
strong performing machine for the first
time since the system's launch the xbox
one has finally outsold sony's
playstation 4. in a statement from
microsoft prior to the official release
of monthly sales numbers from the npd
the company wrote we are amazed by the
excitement xbox fans have shown to start
off this holiday november set a new
record for sales of xbox one and the
xbox one was the best-selling console in
the us and the uk that shouldn't come as
a huge surprise since it was earlier
reported that the xbox outsold the ps4
for two weeks in november as well as
being the number one black friday
console sales were likely bolstered by
the attractive 50 price cut making it
cheaper overall than the ps4 as well as
valued price bundles with new games such
as assassin's creed unity and sunset
overdrive microsoft closed out the
statement saying we love to see the
excitement from our fans and are
grateful for their passion support and
contributions to the xbox community
direct and microsoft can keep up the
momentum and which console will you be
gaming on this holiday you can let us
know down in the comments and for more
news updates keep it tuned to gamespot
you